Yeah,
you know,
when I've read
it sounds really weird,
but when I was about 10 or 11,
I stumbled across the Elliot at home.
My father had bought the great books of
the Western world and one of the first
books,
it was the Elian,
I had no idea what it was,
but it was a very long thing and I
thought this is the beginning of
literature,
so I'm going to read this and I
understood probably about half of it,
but it was fascinating.
It was an incredibly tense,
an interesting story.
And once I got into the whole
way that the,
the,
the poems worked it with like a,
like a swash buckling mystery in a way.
So that made me feel like,
gosh,
this is exciting.
I'd like to do that too.
The one that I remember,
I wrote poems before this,
but the one that I consider the first
real poem was about that time too.
It was an Easter poem.
Um,
it's in school.
We were supposed to write,
write,
or paint or do something artistic for
Easter.
So I wrote this poem called the rabbit
with the droopy ear.
And I remember it because when I began
writing the poem,
I had no idea how it was going to end.
I just had this idea of a rabbit,
the Easter bunny,
who had one ear that you know,
drooped down and he was distressed.
So I kept writing and it rhymed and all
that.
And it was actually the rhyme itself
that helped me solve the problem of a
rabbit with the droopy year.
So the end of the poem goes hip,
hip,
hurray,
let's toast the cup for now.
Both ears were hanging up.
He hanged himself from a tree and his
ears hang straight and everybody's
cheering.
And I was just,
I dunno,
it was very exciting to find that.
And I actually had to read it aloud in
class,
you know,
that was another thing.
Castles were the days when you did these
things in class.
But now people showed their paintings if
they had something from eastern.
I had to read my poem aloud them and
people liked it.
The kids liked my friends.
So that was an instant success story.
It hasn't totally changed.
It's changed in the sense that,
that it's to some extent,
I know,
let's say that the goal is not to come
to some kind of neat solution as that
did,
but um,
but it hasn't changed in the sense that
at some level I'm never quite sure how
the poem is going to resolve itself and
that I'm always in some way surprised.
I make a discovery in a poem once I
write it a buy.
Now that means more accessing the
subconscious and the fact that if I
begin writing a poem on that means I'm
intrigued in some way by whatever it's
about and that if I'm not trying to find
something new and pushing that envelope
in the poem,
I can't expect my reader to be
particularly excited about it either.